welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of the new
trailer of the matrix resurrections a
film that reloads the matrix trilogy
with a fourth film that bloop peels us
back into the simulation with
manipulative nostalgia that makes us all
ask rubber ducky are you the one or am i
that's right i'm starting at the ground
floor of the rabbit hole because the
matrix series is what started my
obsession with film philosophy as a
child too young probably to watch that
movie in 1999 so now i have been waiting
to break this trailer down frame by
frame for all the clues and interesting
details that you might have overlooked
by the way if you like what we do here
at new rockstars the best way to support
us is by checking out some of our merch
options at nurakstarsmerch.com we got
limited edition shirts for marvel's what
if and a shengchi great protector shirt
as well as a brand new adorable morris
stay in the pocket design check them all
out at newrockstarsmerch.com and here we
go
thomas
how can you tell me what happened i've
had dreams that weren't just dreams
we open on sunrise in san francisco now
this exact house is on vallejo street in
russian hill which i only know because
me and my fiance are apartment hunting
in sf and we would rather red pill and
eat tasty wheat goop than pay rent this
damn high anyway notice how the
signature matrix green tinting has been
removed from all this imagery and that's
because matrix revolutions ended with
the deja vu catch trotting over to sati
and the greenness faded away as the
matrix rebooted replaced with saty's
golden sunrise for neo on a seventh
iteration of the matrix in which the
machines and the humans had brokered a
piece thanks to neo sacrificing himself
to rid the matrix of the agent smith
virus and now this new version is
supposed to give humans a choice whether
or not to be enslaved tasty wheat or
cipher meat i want that mate in this
seventh matrix now i say seventh because
we've learned from the architect in the
end of the matrix reloaded that the neo
we have been following is actually the
sixth incarnation of the anomaly so now
this is the seventh matrix that we now
find ourselves in which you could see as
a biblical seventh day of creation the
true beginning and neo has long been
interpreted as a christ figure in death
outstretching his arms in a christ's
pose and now with a title like
resurrection we could be seeing a form
of christ's second coming truly every
detail in this trailer is designed to
stoke deja vu in the viewer the opening
sound is a distorted chime
evoking what neo heard when he saw du
jour's white rabbit tattoo
and when he bent the spoon
[Music]
showing how here we are already going
down the rabbit hole into a bent reality
in the first word of the trailer is neo
being called this
thomas and of course neo seen the deja
vu cat
with the same meow it gave when neo saw
it in the first film
of course the deja vu cat is a warning
not to trust anything we see here and
that there is a glitch in this system
and i'm gonna break down how what we see
in this trailer is not what meets the
eye now the watkowskis have since
confirmed that the matrix trilogy was in
part an allegory for gender identity and
when agent smith continued to call neo
mr anderson it was meant to be a
deliberate hostile misidentification so
the therapist saying thomas you seem
particularly triggered right now should
totally be seen with aggression now the
therapist played by neil patrick harris
wears blue framed glasses and in this
office there's a framed blue butterfly a
blue animal in that globe probably all
associated with the blue pills that he's
probably the one prescribing to neo
which of course in the first film was
the pill that you would take to stay in
the simulation therefore this therapist
could be a program in the matrix similar
to the architect designed to keep neo on
script contrastingly later priyanka
chopra's character wears red framed
glasses and reads lewis carroll's alice
in wonderland through the looking glass
perhaps connected with the red pill that
would wake neo up from the dream i
actually think she might be an adult
version of sati from revolutions and she
could now be the oracle of this version
of the matrix but also on the therapist
desk is a phrenology bust that's the old
pseudoscience in which people would
measure bumps on the skull to predict
mental traits that modern psychologists
collect as decorative pieces i guess to
show look how far we've come now we just
dope people senseless
oh i'm kidding i'm kidding therapy is
actually very very good and very
necessary but not from this therapist
don't trust him neo describes his dreams
that are more likely memories of his
past lives as the matrix's anomaly he
walks down the street of reigning green
code inside of a box that fades away the
code into a normal wet street showing
how neo sees both the simulated facade
and the code underneath then we zoom in
through a numerical zero as we do in the
opening imagery the first film then we
see a man whose eyes roll over with
raining code and then someone firing a
gun and then neo reaching out to catch
that bullet as it ripples through the
air matching that great production
design from the first film and then
neo's body is being plugged back up by
the machine spider bots lasering cuts
into the flesh and notice his eyes are
scarred shut so yes this is neo after
the events of revolutions when he was
physically blinded and when he made that
truce with machines he did seem to die
but now it looks like the machines have
restored his body and plugged him back
into this seventh iteration of the
matrix so it seems like this truce with
machines involves the anomaly being
reinserted and for this whole world to
be crafted for him as confirmed by the
movie's official twitter account in
order to keep neo specifically from
getting out and freeing the minds of too
many of the humans who would now have
more of a choice to do this and so to
make this happen they wipe his memory
yet fragments of his memories are coming
back in his streams and now the matrix
to confront that is trying to gaslight
it all away with blue pills from doogie
howser amd now it has been theorized in
the past that the real world the matrix
films including zion the desert the real
machine city could all be another layer
of the simulation that the machines
created to make some humans think that
they had broken free of the code people
have used this theory to explain how neo
had powers in the real world now i'm not
so sure about that now that we're seeing
neo get re-inserted here and also
because the architect explained how the
machines accounted for one percent of
the human's rebellion in the real world
of zion as part of that cycle and i
think it would be illogical for the
architect to reveal that much but not
also reveal zion being part of a
simulation layer it would also undercut
the themes of determinism versus free
will really if you want endless
ambiguous dream layers there's inception
for that i think the idea is that neo as
the anomaly just has a wireless
connection with the matrix and that's
what makes him so dangerous to the
machines and now necessitates him being
kept inside the program like this
there's a shot of yaya abdulmatine the
second character in a wet shootout with
swat police recalling the fire sprinkers
and morpheus escape in the first film
and also neo and trinity's lobby
shootout actually later yaya does the
same crossed arm shooting that neo did
after he went through the metal
detectors yaya actually confirmed that
he is playing a version of morpheus
which i will talk more about later then
these two hands clasp together and glow
then a quick shot of what looks like
trinity's arrest from the first movies
prologue similar hair but whoever this
is wears a slightly different black
leather outfit with lacing going up the
back interesting why is this part of it
well the teasers on the promotional
website showed more of the scene and
yeah it goes down just like the film's
version does trinity runs up the wall
and it does that slow-motion bullet-time
jump kick these teasers actually show
lots of shots that appear to be
recreated from the first film bullet
casings raining from a helicopter from
above an agent rapid punching someone
against a bathroom wall i'm wondering if
matrix 7.0 might be cycling back through
the events of the past films in order to
justify neo's dream memories as just
part of a public narrative in this
simulation because later in this trailer
we actually see a scene from the 1999
matrix film projected on a screen in a
room so in this new program the matrix
could have restaged the past cycles
revolution events as this world's movies
in video games in order to confuse neo
to make him think that his streams are
fantasies based on the media he consumes
and produces and not things that really
happened kind of like how cipher wanted
to be re-inserted into the matrix this
way i don't remember nothing nothing you
understand and i want to be rich
you know
someone important
like an actor which i like to think is
how keanu and joey pants wake up every
morning is this all a simulation is that
why they wrote those lines for me in
that movie and yeah it's gonna be real
fun how this movie engages over
imaginative viewers who believe movies
like the matrix and the truman show were
made to make us see conspiracies that
are really happening as just mere
hollywood fantasies but i really do
think we're looking at some being john
malkovich craziness happening in this
movie in that the ip we know as a matrix
exists in this simulation then we see a
vast human gestation pod with a person
sitting up if you look closely i assume
that's neo sitting up in the next shot
seems to be waking up from the
simulation briefly but this pod faces
another one and it looks like these two
have a private chamber as opposed to
joining the rows and rows of millions of
pods neo could be seen trinity's pod
because both of them appear to be
reinserted actually there was another
shot from that website red pill teaser
showing two unplugged humans being
attacked by sentinels viciously and the
human on the right reaches out to the
other i wonder if these are neo and
trinity freed in unplugging attempts
since then but they were caught in the
act by sentinels then sequestered by the
machines in this private chamber
impossible to unplug through the
traditional means then we see a quick
shot of someone snapping can't tell who
but there's that fancy ring a cuff link
and suit and some woman in the
background i'm wondering if this could
be the maravincian with persephone
behind him because it seems like this
matrix 4 movie is bringing back
everything from the trilogy all right
let's move on
am i crazy
we don't use that word in here
ah crazy we don't use that word in here
you can see how even that rattles neo as
if his next question is what other rules
do you have in here what exactly are we
in and who is we do you and the deja vu
cat get the answers cut now the music in
this trailer is jefferson airplane's
white rabbit a perfect if
bit on the nose extension of the alice
in wonderland motif from the first film
morpheus saying i bet you feel a bit
like alice and in this song the lyrics
come from the point of view of the
stoned caterpillar talking about the eat
me cake and the drink meat tea but in
this case using the term pill
reimagining them as psychedelic drugs as
the matrix does with the eye opening red
pill and the inhibiting blue pill neo
sits in a bathtub with a rubber ducky on
his head this could be a reference to
rubber duck debugging coming from a
story about a programmer who carried
around with a rubber duck and as he
debugged his code line by line he had to
explain it to the duck neo in the first
movie was a coder and a hacker so this
could be something he actually does and
on a metaphorical level he is currently
trying to debug the code of the matrix
that he is stuck in neo and trinity
shake hands in this coffee shop and
there's as little electric hum as they
touch
yes literal sparks of recognition
between them similar to how in lost the
final season everyone's favorite era of
lost physical touch reminded partners
that they knew each other in a parallel
life remember neo's connection to
trinity is what differentiated him from
the past anomalies he chose differently
and so his anomalistic status might now
be linked with trinity that's why
they're sequestered together by the
machines why they're both reinserted and
can't escape and that only together they
can break the confines of this reality
and the website teasers neo approaches a
coffee shop called simulate another on
the nose element that actually thought
might have been something in a video
game based on his matrix memories that
neo is now building but here you can see
that green simulates sign behind neo
here and yes it is green because because
matrix neo medicates with blue pills
which he takes a handful of at a time
now in the website blue pill teaser you
can see on the prescription bottle label
it's addressed to thomas anderson one
pill taken daily do not exceed well
broke that rule and it's called
antalafloxin based on the term ontology
which is a branch of metaphysics that
explores the nature of being so yeah
this drug is literally subduing one's
overreaching perception of reality now
you've heard us talk about how helix
mattresses are customized to fit your
specific sleep needs well helix also
makes awesome customized furniture
through the company all forms all form
lets you personalize a sofa using
premium materials at a fraction of the
cost of traditional stores you pick a
fabric the color of the legs sofa size
and shape to fit you and your home if
you invite some friends or family over
to watch the latest episode of what if
don't make uncle rick sit on a folding
chair all form has everything from
armchairs to eight-seat sectionals uncle
rick will have tons of sitting options
new rockstars editor john got a brown
leather armchair and ottoman from all
form last year he cannot stop gabby
about his super comfortable all form
chairs that's a nice chair all form
sofas are delivered directly to your
home with fast free shipping they'll get
you your custom furniture in just three
to seven days and you can assemble it
yourself in a few minutes no
tools needed you get 100 days to decide
if you want to keep it and if you do not
love it they'll pick it up for free and
give you a full refund they even offer a
forever warranty literally forever like
the third batman movie to find your
perfect sofa check out allform.com
new rockstars and all form is offering
20 off all orders for our audience at
allform.com
new rockstars the moment neo takes the
pills one of his many mirror surfaces
reflects him as an old man which in a
different mirror later in this trailer
shows him as well here that might be why
neo now stares bewildered at the mirror
and not because as i do every time i
look in a mirror we see a little devil
waving at us from insider peoples but
why old neo well we know from the past
films that mirrors are very important to
the world of the matrix it's how a
character expresses their true selves
and how they transcend their realities
so maybe this is how neo looks to others
in the simulated reality or maybe it's
how his older self would look like had
he been allowed to age normally in the
real world or perhaps we're seeing the
original one the og anomaly who freed
the humans from the first matrix but
then we see a quick flash of neo's eye
opening in an all-white setting looking
similar to neo's eyes opening when he
first entered the construct for the
first time and then neo outside looks up
at some bird formation seeing something
irregular in the way that they flock
maybe perhaps feeling an instinct to
take flight himself but find himself
unable to do so that could be why yaya
later offers him time to fly neo zen in
an elevator filled with employees glued
to their devices a way that the first
matrix film proved to be eerily
prophetic for how modern society would
like cipher choose to be attached all
the time to our digital simulated
realities hold on a second i love you
this actually could be another insidious
way the seventh matrix program
manipulates humans in this world to stay
plugged in by upgrading our technology
to make us addicted to it could be a
reason why our greatest technological
advances in the past couple decades have
shifted from things like the space race
to consumer tech and i guess in the past
years shifted back to the space race but
like only billionaires can do it just
kind of way of the program making us
think it's attainable for us
i really love this from below shot aimed
at the mirror's ceiling of the elevator
making neo feel even more boxed in by
technology and the camera should be
visible in shot between the two people
with tablets but they removed it
digitally a step up from one of the
goofiest one of my favorite shots in the
first matrix when they tried to hide the
camera in the doorknob reflection
practically with morpheus jacket then
neo back at his bathroom mirror with a
handful of blue pills way more than
could possibly fit in that one bottle he
may have discovered a glitch that no
matter how many blue pills he takes or
he flushes the one prescription keeps
automatically refilling which if you
think about it is kind of the way a lot
of people in real life get overly
medicated with automatically refilling
prescriptions then neo enters this
chinese restaurant folks this blew my
mind when i realized this because this
is actually my favorite restaurant in
san francisco house of nang king i have
been to it several times actually lamely
took a picture of this tea that you get
with a flower that blooms as you drink
it but if you live in san francisco
please don't go there because the line
gets long enough anyway in the matrix
this might actually be the noodle place
that neo mentioned who used to eat that
really good noodles and house of nan
king does have good noodles next time i
eat them i'm gonna be like
ignorance
here he meets bianca chopra's character
who again might be the older sati and
the new oracle of the seventh matrix and
a great slick of jefferson airplane
sings go ask alice right as priyanka
closes the book of alice in wonderland
now in the next shot behind neo at that
mirror is a shot of keanu from the
unplugging scene in the first film it's
right before he looks over at the broken
mirror in that scene now this looks to
be set in some kind of old-timey cinema
that we actually see later in the
trailer projecting the shot from the
first film when the mirror goo creeps up
keanu's neck now again this could be a
simulation where matrix movies exist as
pop culture in this world or maybe we're
seeing a hacker group have access to
these secret reels showing a parallel
reality like the alt reality reels and
man the high castle great show you
should check it out and then notice how
the technical interface in front of that
screen in the cinema looks a lot like
the setup they had when they unplugged
neo from the matrix that could be what's
happening here because we see now these
film projector beams behind yaya's
character as he offers neo a red pill or
a blue pill he's wearing the red shirt i
assume he wants to take the red pill and
neo having to take endless numbers of
the blue one every day yeah he's gonna
want the red pill now when we last saw
morpheus in the trilogy he was in the
real world after the machine's retreat
from the battle of zion asking is this
real now assuming morpheus remains free
others may have rebooted morpheus's
younger coding hoping neo might
recognize it there is a shot in the
website teaser showing the iai's
character's body being formed together
in a blue chamber so he could be a false
reboot of morpheus being created by the
machines neo then sees a white rabbit
tattoo on the arm of jessica henwick's
character like the one on de jour's arm
she opens his rooftop door with this
bright light actually having an excuse
to put on sunglasses at night that's new
for this series now this impossible door
recalls the key maker from reloaded and
notice all that random flooding on the
rooftop this door might open up to
somewhere wet but we know it's a
different scene than henwick and neo
stepping in through the mirror because
neo is now wearing different clothes neo
and trinity hold hands again as green
code rains down her face this might be
another dream vision it might actually
be how neo recognizes trinity in the
coffee shop later also in this garage is
trinity's motorcycle from matrix
reloaded neo and yaya's character spar
in a place similar to the dojo from the
construct in the first film you don't
know me
no
damn i love how neo clearly doesn't
physically touch yaya here it's really
his telekinetic impact blast that blows
a place apart then on the this christmas
title green lines of code stream down
and up maybe a way of showing how this
seventh matrix runs on two sources of
coding the source from the architect but
also its embedded anomalies neo and
trinity they just don't know yet how
much control they have over it then we
see the desert to the real the columns
of human pods as harvesting machines
snake morphods down their tubes you also
see a swarm of sentinels weaving past
then you see a human hovercraft
exploring what could be the ruins of a
human city i thought at first this could
be zion but there is light coming in
meaning this actually must be closer to
the surface remember trinity briefly saw
the earth's beautiful atmosphere above
the clouds and revolutions but otherwise
the surface was still cast in shadow but
maybe now the machines have been working
to repair the earth's ecosystem as part
of this truce and as part of this truce
humans might be allowed to come nearer
to the surface then we see neo and
trinity on a rooftop a later shot shows
neo redirecting a missile into another
helicopter causing it to crash into this
rooftop i love how it causes the side of
the building to undulate just like the
building glass did in the first film
when the helicopter crashed into it
henwick flees swat officers by doing
this acrobatic leap onto a lower ledge
smashing it similar to the way morpheus
smashed the scaffolding as he stuck his
landing from his big jump then a cop
gets overtaken by an agent actually we
learned daniel bernhardt is actually
confirmed to return to resurrections as
agent johnson from matrix reloaded neo
faces this gun pointed at his face by
someone who's out of focus not sure who
it is but water is sprinkling from
overhead and notice how neo is rubbing
his fingers like he is seeing this rain
as code this stressful moment could be
actually what triggers his reawakening
and his ability to see the matrix code
then back to the cinema where the
projector screen is showing neo's
unplugging moment in the 1999 film on a
torn projector screen as the swat
officer fires an rpg through it and the
target is through this door behind the
screen another impossible door because
it opens up from a cabin on a japanese
bullet train penwick's character neo
yaya and another flee up the aisle as
the other guy ducks the rocket explodes
rocking the train car as it's beating up
past japanese cherry blossom trees
toward mount fuji then neo and yaya face
an explosive shootout in this office
this might be neo's workspace from that
elevator shot earlier and on the wall
there's a sign labeling it deus ex
machina it's a term from ancient greek
theater translating to god from the
machine in which actors playing greek
gods would be lowered in via mechanized
crane to rescue characters from their
earthbound crises and today it's a term
used really to refer to divine
intervention in stories but in matrix
revolutions deus ex machina was the name
given to the central interface in
machine city whom neo formed that truce
with and now deus ex machina could be
the name of the production company or
game developer where thomas anderson
works crafting his dreams of his past
lives into consumable media which would
be another ironic reflection of the
machina that put neo in this simulation
then this very interesting shot of
trinity in a kind of machine goo pod but
beneath the head jack used normally to
plug humans into the simulation there is
a secondary jack at the base of her neck
with a blue tube feeding into it we
actually saw the second jack in close-up
in the website teaser the matrix might
now need this stronger hard line to
bypass whatever hole the anomalies have
over the system and in the matrix it
could take the form of neil patrick
harris's therapist character who pumps
them full of blue pills now a big reason
i think trinity is part of neo's anomaly
is she has some extraordinary powers as
well even more than she did in the
previous films she releases a freaking
shock wave when she hits soldiers and
then she has this moment where she
screams splitting herself into a
spectrum these split forms do not all
look like trinity in fact the one on the
far right looks a bit like christina
ricci she is playing some role in this
film and she might be the variant
trinity who restaged the matrix one
scene i'll just say this is interesting
imagery for a character named trinity
her name referring to the christian
concept of one god in three persons yaya
touches a mirror that turns into fluid
this could be part of his unplugging
moment since the mirror responded like
this for neo when he was getting
unplugged henwick flees police and joins
yaya through this awesome impossible
door which rotates upside down in the
destination hallway now notice yaya is
dressed like an agent here in fact he
has a second pair of sunglasses over his
pinch sunglasses yaya might be under
some kind of weird program that cloaks
him as an agent then this shot where
someone crashes through a window
followed by a second person a few floors
below but then we cut from below to see
yaya and henwick falling but in the
previous shot those were very different
people one person was barefoot so
whatever is going on here yaya and
himwick now crash through a surface and
plunge into a world of code in the
website teasers neo steps off a ledge
and then another scene jumps off the
building with trinity we could be seeing
a kind of leap of faith to test an
unfinished piece of code a bug in the
system that rubber ducky didn't catch
and then neo and trinity together blow
back dozens of soldiers in that
simulated coffee shop you can see a
black and white version of the green
sign that we saw earlier this could be
that close-up of the hands clasping that
we saw earlier in the trailer then neo
stops a hail of bullets but notice
trinity is also grabbing his arm i think
both need to be together for their full
anomalistic properties to function then
two on a motorcycle plowing through a
swarm of civilians notice their eyes are
glowing green might be like that guy
whose eyes filled with green code
earlier maybe the matrix has now
weaponized just average street folks as
drones to try to tackle neo but the
final shot shows neo chatting with
jonathan groff's character after all
these years to be going back to where it
all started
back to the matrix i think this is a
misdirect and groff's character might be
the owner of the company thomas anderson
works for if it's a movie studio or game
developer and he's referring to anderson
going back to reboot his ip of the
matrix in this world like a studio head
telling an actor really you're going to
reboot that property or game developer
head saying really you want to do
another enter the matrix it's art
reflecting life reflecting art
reflecting life a meta commentary on the
very concept of reboots in general being
meaningless capitalistic nostalgia
machines because from the first act of
the first matrix film the wachowskis
grounded this franchise in the
philosophy of jean beaujouri's simulacra
and simulation the book that neo was
holding bulgeriard explores how society
is now based on simulations of real
things and how we're really just as
emotionally attached to the
representation of something than we are
to the real thing and i love how neo
fills this book with hacker hardware and
with cash turning beauty yard's treaties
on holo simulations into a literal
hollow simulation of something now in
the website teaser groff's mouth glues
shut like neo's mouth did in the first
film when he was interrogated by agent
smith i wonder if neo who's finally
trying to shut up his boss might be able
to bend reality now to make it happen
now this film is releasing on december
22nd 2021 i don't know if this is a
coincidence or not but 12 22 21 is a
palindrome connecting back to the
importance of mirrors in this series as
expressions of identity and also thanks
for picking a movie date that's going to
make us all have to work through
christmas ho ho ho but i'm excited to
see it hey you can follow me on
instagram and twitter at eavos follow
and subscribe to new rockstars for
analysis of all the movies you love
probably a bit too much thanks for
watching bye
[Music]
you